all right there are a lot of questions
and concerns regarding our local real
estate market so i checked in
with palacios realty to get an update
take a look
it's springtime so and the market the
real estate market is ever evolving so
what is it looking like
for this season my goodness well last
month we had 5 000 closings
happen uh that by uh comparison is 1300
closings more than we had the month
before uh that has
moved our inventory shortage even
shorter to half of a month uh so we are
still seeing multiple offers we're still
seeing buyers pay cash out of pocket
uh in addition to their closing costs so
to help cover the appraisal gaps
uh that's kind of what we're working on
right now we have our work cut out for
us
for sure now is this a negative or
positive
i keep hearing that we could be on our
way towards a crash situation
so tell us what's going on that end we
hear this every day
it is a natural concern considering it's
you know we're fresh out of the great
recession
uh but there are four factors that we
know why we are not headed towards a
bubble uh the first one being equity
nationwide 60 of the homeowners have
more than 50
equity 30 of those don't even have a
mortgage
so when we look at that along with
buyers affordability buyers can actually
afford more home today
we're actually paying less out of pocket
in our monthly expenses
just to buy a home than we did 15 plus
years ago
lending standards is another reason why
we are in a different
place because uh when the great
recession happened they eliminated the
risky standards for the last 13 years
we've been performing
under the 50-year marker and finally
appreciation
i mean the demand that we're seeing now
is hasn't changed
simply our our inventory has changed and
that's why we're seeing prices go up
uh and so it is appropriate to see those
prices adjust and that that
those are the four reasons why we're not
headed towards the crash because
everything is is on a solid foundation
we're headed in the right direction for
everything
we just simply need more home so uh if
you're thinking
obviously please have a consultation we
absolutely want to help you uh but that
will absolutely help also the the uh
the tolerance of home prices kind of go
there so faster we can do it please
let's do it okay well that's good news
it's always nice to know that we're not
headed towards a crash
uh my last question here is you know
obviously selling a home is great you
make that money back
but what if you sell your home and
there's no home
for you to buy because inventory is so
low
yes and that is also a question we get
common in our consultations
we actually have 10 points to consider
and each of those are
very unique and specific to every
situation just an example
we can always negotiate a lease back for
a buyer to get into one
uh to be able to purchase and transfer
into the house another one
let's consider a recast with your new
loan
that is a special unique and uh cool
trick i'd love to be able to talk more
about that
uh in a personal consultation for
someone who's really interested in that
give palacios realty a call at 702
702-333-666-6
and check out their special offer
mention channel 8 for a free
one-year home warranty with home
purchase we'll be right back right here
on